tenemos aquí un triángulo a de c
en el vídeo anterior ya empezamos a
explorar algunas ideas de puntos que
estaban sobre las bisectriz es de
algunos ángulos lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es ver qué sucede al aplicar
esas ideas en el caso de un triángulo
entonces déjame empezar visitando el
ángulo b a c voy a trazar la bisectriz
tiene que ser una recta que corte el
ángulo justo a la mitad entonces va a
quedar algo más o menos así vale
entonces eso de ahí es una bisectriz
entonces podemos decir que este ángulo
de aquí es igual a este ángulo de acá y
no sé a este punto en el cual corta a
veces le vamos a llamar el punto de
saleh
entonces el ángulo b a d es igual al
ángulo c a d
ok ahora déjame dibujar la bisectriz del
ángulo que está en b es decir el ángulo
abs es a la voy a pintar con otro color
digamos con color azul bueno con color
verde mejor entonces voy a tomar ahora
la bisectriz que sale desde v más o
menos una recta silva
a este punto en donde corta le voy a
llamar el punto y como esto de aquí es
una bisectriz entonces bishek está el
ángulo y por lo tanto el ángulo ave y
ave es congruente al ángulo cb y este de
aquí es congruente a éste de acá muy
bien ahora observemos que estas dos
bisectriz es se cortan en un punto en el
interior del triángulo entonces déjame
marcar ese punto de ahí le voy a poner a
este punto el nombre y y puede parecer
un nombre muy loco o sea ponerle y es
algo súper raro pero ahorita vamos a
justificar por qué se llama vale por el
momento vamos a ver algunas propiedades
interesantes del punto i
para empezar vamos a usar que está sobre
la bisectriz del ángulo b hace por lo
que vimos en el vídeo pasado eso quiere
decir que y va a ser equidistante de los
dos lados de los dos lados que definen
este ángulo es decir iba a ser
equidistante de ave y de ac así que
déjame marcar esto de alguna forma
entonces la distancia de y hace la
distancia y aquí recuerda que para para
marcar la distancia necesitamos bajar
una perpendicular porque es la distancia
más corta entonces esta distancia de acá
va a ser igual a esta distancia de acá a
esta distancia de acá vale entonces
déjame ponerle algún nombre a este punto
de aquí no sé vamos a llamarle quizás el
punto f a donde en donde baja la
perpendicular y a éste le vamos a llamar
el punto g vale entonces aquí tenemos un
punto que entonces tenemos que y es
equidistante de ave y hace y por lo
tanto f es igual a g lo voy a apuntar
por aquí en algún lado tenemos que ir
efe es igual a dije muy bien eso fue
porque y estaba en esta bisectriz morada
a la de v ac pero además y por cómo lo
construimos está en la bisectriz del
ángulo a bs entonces y también es
equidistante de ave con bs ya tenemos la
distancia de la ave que es esta de acá
es ig ahora déjame marcar la distancia
de y abc entonces ahora hay que bajar
una perpendicular para acá una
perpendicular para acá vale entonces
tenemos que esta distancia es igual a
ésta y también que esta distancia es
igual a ésta vale como y esta en esta
bisectriz también tenemos que y ge y ge
es igual a le voy a llamar este punto h
es igual a y h vale pero combinando
estas dos igualdades concluimos o sea
así
efe es igual a y ge y ge es igual y h
entonces podemos concluir que
efe efe es igual a y h pero entonces
sucede algo interesante
tenemos que y es un punto que también
equidista del lado b c y del lado hace
porque aquí las distancias y h y de este
lado la distancia es
efe por lo tanto por el otro lado de la
afirmación que vimos en el vídeo
anterior obtenemos que y también está
sobre la bisectriz del ángulo hace ve
déjame escribir esto por acá tenemos que
ir
y la bisectriz en la bisectriz bisectriz
actriz del ángulo de c
dv le voy a poner a se ve entonces eso
está muy interesante observa que y es un
punto que lo tomamos en dos bisectriz es
pero resulta que también está en la
tercera déjame trazar esa tercer
bisectriz digamos con color pues con
este color naranja que estoy usando va
que todavía no lo he puesto en la figura
entonces tenemos tenemos que y también
está en esa bisectriz y entonces eso es
algo padre porque esto nos dice que las
tres bisectriz es pasan por un mismo
punto por este punto de aquí que es el
punto y y eso es algo especial verdad o
sea en general cuando tenemos tres
rectas no tienen porqué interceptarse en
un mismo punto si tenemos dos rectas
pues sí o sea se intersectan en uno y
sólo un punto pero que tres rectas pasen
por un mismo punto es algo realmente
especial de hecho eso es algo pues
también especial que pasaba con las
media tristes te acuerdas también
habíamos visto que las tres media
tristes pasaban por un único punto al
cual le llamábamos el círculo centro era
un punto especial y aquí también tenemos
que y es un punto bien especial verdad
es una intersección
rectas entonces sería bueno ponerle un
nombre pues resulta que ya tiene un
nombre va a este punto y que es el punto
de la intersección de las tres bises
tristes se le conoce como el in centro
de ave se lo voy a apuntar de este lado
y se le conoce como el in centro el in
centro de el triángulo abc y ahorita
vamos a ver por qué se llama así de
hecho en unos 15 segundos vamos a ver
por qué se llama así
entonces y ese link centro de abs antes
cuando teníamos a o el circo un centro
pues ese era el centro de una
circunferencia que pasaba por ave hice
una circunferencia circunscrita al
triángulo pero ahora éste se va a llamar
un centro porque va a ser el centro de
una circunferencia inscrita o sea una
circunferencia que está por dentro del
triángulo abc y de hecho va a ser una
circunferencia que están gente a los
tres lados del triángulo bueno y como ya
hacemos entonces para construir esta
circunferencia bueno pues ya mostramos
que dije que es igual a h que es igual a
efe entonces cómo estás
estas tres longitudes son iguales
digamos a una cierta longitud r tenemos
que al trazar una circunferencia con
centro y radio r es la circunferencia va
a pasar por estos tres vértices pero
estos tres puntos son los más cercanos
en cada uno de los lados hay esa
circunferencia justo va a ser tangente a
cada uno de los lados déjame ver si
puedo dibujarla decentemente con la
herramienta de circunferencias entonces
voy a agarrar pues el color blanco está
bien entonces vamos a ver qué pasa
entonces quedaría algo más o menos así
vale para entonces quedó decente aquí
debe ser tangente en el punto f de este
lado debe ser tangente en el punto g y
aquí están gente en el punto h bueno
pues a esta circunferencia que está
inscrita a b y c se le conoce de dos
formas déjalo a punto por aquí lo voy a
poner en otro color con este color azul
que está bonito entonces aquí está el
centro a la circunferencia a la
circunferencia que tiene el centro y que
tiene esto como radio esta distancia
como radio se le conoce como la como la
circunferencia inscrita déjame ponerlo
así circunferencia circunferencia
inscrita inscrita o bien también se le
conoce como el círculo en sí un círculo
círculo de abs un triángulo a bs
entonces podrías encontrarte de estos
dos nombres en la literatura sale y a
este radio el radio que tiene la
circunferencia inscrita a r se le conoce
como el radio el radio y la radio del
triángulo
a veces muy bien entonces antes teníamos
una circunferencia circunscrita con un
circo un centro y un círculo radio pero
ahora donde se intersectan las bisectriz
es es un un centro y a partir de ese
centro y elin radio que es la distancia
de los lados
podemos construir la circunferencia
inscrita o bien un círculo